tia cost je dirais que nous voyons avant
précisément que les militaires français
sont pour l'instant pratiquement les
seuls soldats occidentaux présents sur
le terrain dans le cadre de l'opération
turquoise une opération qui était
militaire au départ pour assurer une
zone de sécurité dans le sud du pays
mais la mission vous allez le voir
aujourd'hui est radicalement différente
françois cordier creuser des fosses
communes à la pelleteuse pour y enterrer
les morts atteint du choléra que l'on va
recouvrir de shawville mais au rwanda on
manque aussi cruellement de chaux vive
une mission également à la charge des
militaires français
car celui ci disposent d'engins de
terrassement
il faut faire vite et creusé au rythme
des ravages de l'épidémie pénible
mission humanitaire qui n'était pas
prévu au programme mais qu'il faut bien
assumer dans le ciel à basse altitude
les transall français larguait des
vivres souvent les propres ration des
unités en attendant celles qui
n'arrivent pas infirmiers et médecins
militaires poursuivent sur le terrain
leur moisson de blessés d'éclopés
parfois le miracle se produit un enfant
sauvé de l'enfer des militaires au
secours des orphelins la demande des
organisations humanitaires
l'image une fois encore peu commune bien
loin des missions initiales de
l'opération turquoise
oui notre mission évolué elle était
d'abord de protection était d'abord axé
sur la sécurité et elle passe maintenant
davantage sur l'humanitaire c'est à dire
ce qu'est médical ce qui est vivre ce
qu'ils regroupement des populations
alors nous maintenons la zone de
sécurité est d'ailleurs en accord en
grande partie maintenant avec le fpr
c'est à dire avec le nouveau
gouvernement rwandais mai
faisons en sorte que le drame la
catastrophe humanitaire qui est en train
de se dérouler sous nos yeux notamment à
goma mais aussi à bukavu puisse être
endiguée par des moyens militaires
également dans la mesure de nos moyens
bien sûr avec 2200 hommes au rwanda la
france mène donc maintenant de front
deux types de missions l'humanitaire et
la protection d'une zone de sécurité
dans le sud-est du pays représentant le
sixième du territoire rwandais dans
laquelle sont réfugiées 1 million 700
mille hutu ou tutsi
une zone de sécurité où la situation
s'est stabilisée après le désarmement
des anciennes forces gouvernementales et
des milices et qui n'est pas elle
contrairement à la région de goma au
nord touchée par les épidémies mais qui
manquent cependant cruellement de ville